right or even just Adrienne or Stella
you know just it could just be one name
what about names
speaking of which names of characters
the interesting thing I think everybody
comes up with names in a different way
what the problem with me for names is
there's too many names so it's like
people go oh I get my names from the
phonebook and it's like dude look
through all those names man how do I
choose one over another and so what I
was trying to do is figure out a palette
let's say of names so my palette of
names ends up being something where I
will decide I did a terrible movie that
got released by Lionsgate so maybe it's
not all that terrible called crooked but
nobody should ever see it is really bad
it's nothing like my script either it's
like one of the few movies that I've
seen where it's like that's not even my
idea what happened and I'm the only
screenwriter credited on it but
everything changed but the thing with
that movie was I decided I was gonna use
the names of screenwriters of film noir
movies so I made this gigantic list you
know there's like we're dealing with
hundreds and hundreds of movies and so
you have hundreds of names and then you
look at the names to go this name fits
that character this name fits that
character and basically by creating a
palette you know instead of going
through the whole phone book but
sometimes you collect names so that I
watched a news story once where somebody
something happened to when they were
robbed wherever but their name was dark
way
dar qu a oh that's why
and I'm like dark ways an awesome name
man so that goes like you know you put
it in a notebook dark way sometime that
names gonna come out and and sometimes
you hear names where you go that isn't
that it's an amazing name
the thing about names is hard sounds and
soft sounds and multiple syllables gives
you different ideas of who the
characters are so if a character has
hard sounds and their names that makes
them a harder character then somebody
with soft sounds in their names if you
have a villain I like to have villains
henchmans names in with s because it's a
hiss not about a kiss at the end but
multiple syllables sometimes again this
gets into trying out names verbally
because if somebody's going to be
calling a character by name it's gotta
sound good coming out of somebody's
mouth
which kind of by the way gets into
dialogue dialogue often needs to play on
screen so some lines of dialogue work
perfect on the page but when you say
them out loud have a different meaning
so and this is like the accidental pun
so if you have two guys discussing a
bank robbery in a men's room and one guy
says you know you're in it suddenly has
a totally different meaning because
they're in a men's room and somebody
says urine and so you want to look for
those things and basically look how
dialogue sounds the oh man there's a
tale out of school but here he goes
anyway the first script that I sold to
Paramount Pictures
I had a development executive that
wanted a character I had a character
that said it's dangerous and she wanted
to change the line of dialogue to it's
risky and that sounds right except when
you say risky it's you smile sort of
there's a smile sound too risky and so
when a character says it's risky and
they smile it no it doesn't become
dangerous and now becomes it's risky but
I'm up for it instead of it's dangerous
and I could die
so sometimes words if you know words
when you look at yourself in the mirror
when you say the words your face comes
up with an expression that's the
opposite of what you meant and that can
work for you or against you depending
upon whether you know you know what what
what that opposite thing is you can have
a character say that sounds are risky to
me and it's got that smile sound in it
where that's too dangerous character
names that describe the archetype of the
character and let's say there's a lot of
female characters these days that are
supposed to be sort of these cool girls
that have men's names so it makes them
sort of archetype thing here's the thing
you want you don't want dark way is a
good character name because it sounds
real you don't want to have these these
names like I'm trying to think of a
face-off has some of the worst character
names ever you know
because the characters are all named
after Greek whatever so you have through
what's castor Troy and they don't sound
real
you know they sound like somebody went
through the Greek mythology book and
said hey here's a name here's a name
here's a name so you don't want to do
that you also don't want to have names
that are too on-the-nose for characters
where it's it describes their their
actual name describes who the character
is you don't want that instead what you
want or maybe the things that are like a
couple of generations removed from that
so the audience doesn't necessarily if
that's how you're coming up with
character names the audience's doesn't
necessarily jump from you know I can't
think of a good example right now only
because I'm not wired to come up with
these on-the-nose names you know but you
know there's there's you know I wish I
had an example but the names the the the
tomboy names like Sam and things like
that here's the the sometimes problem
with Nate with character names is you
can come up with a character name that
sounds good but when you read it on
paper we suddenly see a different person
and so I have a script that's fantastic
voyage in a computer which probably
could never be made now because our
computers are all so small it's
fantastic voyage in an iPhone but the
idea was I have five scientists and five
badass Marines go through virtual
reality inside a computer to deal with a
virus think it's way out again but the
problem was I the doctor the scientist
were all doctor this doctor this doctor
this the military the Marines were all
is whatever their rank was except I came
up with sergeant Burt with one problem
sergeant Burton was a woman so when you
read it you never think it's a woman and
she lost her sex by the name so I
thought I can't have her be sergeant
Burton because the when you're reading
it on the page you don't see that she's
a woman and nobody's going to flip back
you this a guy or gal you know it's
never gonna happen so I thought I need
to come up with a name that's better
than her first name was Betsy so she
became Sergeant Betsy and again when you
do that change suddenly the character
Changez so sergeant Betsy went from
being the badass female marine to being
the badass
cheerleader female marine because Betsy
has kind of this weird sort of a for me
at least a cheerleader type connotation
and I made her the spunky you know
upbeat badass marine and so now sergeant
Betsy went through there and her
character kind of changed once that name
came on there but look for it's easy to
when a character just becomes the
character slug when they stop being the
description get the description you know
on page one and now we're on page forty
you're not going to remember who that
description is so their name has to have
something that reminds us who that
character is in a case you know in the
the baddest Marines it's great to have
the you know that the character name
again hard sound character names they're
the badass scientists more syllables and
less hard sounds for the scientists so
we sort of get the idea that the
scientists are less you know macho well
going back to Betsy I feel like she
would either have been born in the 50s
60s or 70s because I heard that name
from those eras where as if she was
maybe a millennial or even after it
would be Sam yeah or it would be we see
the thing is Sam D sex is the character
whereas you know if she's Samantha that
can work with once we say Sam it D sex
is the character and so what happens is
you're on page forty and you read Sam
and suddenly in your mind you go what to
do and then Sam's making out with with
Ben and you're going okay you know it's
and you know that that can confuse the
reader so you the thing to always do is
to always look for what could confuse
the reader and if you're thinking about
you know we we have this you know this
fantasy that someone's going to read our
script with care and what's happening is
there are in the old days there used to
be freelance readers that got paid 35 to
50 bucks a script and in order to pay
rent in Los Angeles that meant they were
taking home stacks of scripts a day just
they have to read the whole script
because they have to write up a coverage
report but at the same time that doesn't
mean they're gonna read every word
they're gonna do a lot of skimming and
that leads to confusion if you have
those ambiguous names like Sam sometimes
so that's one of those things that could
be a problem but those the problem now
is those were the good old days when
they got paid 35 to 50 bucks a day now
they're unpaid interns who get paid
nothing and are reading your script and
so they put in as much they put in no
dollars worth of care for your script
which means your script really has to
jump off the page and get them but
they're posting status updates to while
they're absolutely absolutely a friend
of mine posts worst lines he read in a
script today and I'm not going to give
you his name but but they're awful lines
you just go somebody typed that it got
from the brain through the fingers under
the keyboard into the laptop
you